and I went to those guys to the beef
check off and I said he look we want to
spend a little bit of money to do a
study on beef versus diabetes because we
know the results you're going to be then
the people are going to they're going to
go on an all meat diet or close to all
meat diet their diabetes is going to go
away it's it's simple and it takes all
the confusion out because whenever you
do you know you hear all these dietary
studies it's like oh but he was eating
hamburgers and french fries and there's
all this confounder so and it's like you
can't really test it I'm like the
perfect way to test if meat is healthy
or not is to just put them on a damn
carnivore diet and see what happens it's
the only way to test if you do an
epidemiology study and you don't account
for sugar sugary drink Coca-Cola bread
pasta lasagna that's exactly that's what
Harford did recently they didn't account
for sugar intake when they said beef
causes diabetes like you got to be
kidding me you're not even counting
sugar that's so crazy right but they but
they get this published and this is
really bad science you know and guys
like uh John aniis who's a who's a one
of the most cited scientists in the
world has basically said all this
epidemiology we're doing we're just
wasting money it's not telling us
anything it's all garbage but they keep
doing it over and over again because
they generate headlines you know the
headlines I want but anyway back to this
beef check off thing so I I I said hey
look you know every year you award money
you know hundreds of th you know tens of
millions of dollars to promote beef I
said let's get a little bit of money to
do a research study on diabetes and they
literally said no we're not interested
in doing that and I'm like you got to be
kidding me the beef industry is taking a
beating right now you know you you
listen to it it's like um you know
everybody wants to get rid of beef it's
there the cow farts are boiling the
oceans and
uh you know it's going to kill you it's
going to give you cancer which all of it
is largely nonsense and this is a you
know in my view this type of study would
clearly clearly
demonstrate um that not only does beef
not cause diabetes in fact I talked to
the CEO of the ncba two years ago I sat
down I presented in front of the
California cattelan's Association and
literally the president of Association
stood up and said I went on a conver out
and cured my diabetes it's like yeah
it's clear and the guy said yeah I get
it we're going to help you out we're
going to get this going I didn't hear I
he nothing from these guys so what I
think's going on is the USDA kind of
oversees all these checkouts and they
just kind of say look you can't say that
because we want to promote you know
because again they have all these
processed food lobbies abisco and
PepsiCo sitting on the you know they're
on the board and they're like if we
promote this one food and people stop
eating all this processed food right
then what are we going to do we're going
to lose a lot of money you think about
it you know not that I'm advocating that
everybody going to carnivore or die CU I
don't think that's I don't think it's
necessary from you know for for one but
if you significantly cut back on all the
people consuming all this garbage you
know what what does that do economically
to this country I mean you think about
how much money is spent on garbage food
the drugs that are needed to treat that
you're talking I mean we spent four $4.3
trillion do a year on on healthc care in
this country and what do we get for it
we got one of the sickest populations in
the world our life expectancy is going
down everybody's fat everybody's
depressed everybody's on trucks you know
it's crazy it is crazy and it's crazy
that they don't look to diet as being
the primary cause of that or if they do
they look to these epidemiology studies
that don't take into account exactly
what you're eating with the meat why is
it meat that's always demonized well I
think for a number of reasons one if you
go back to like dietetics in the
beginning like back in 1917 the American
dietetics Association was formed this
was formed literally by sth Day
Adventist so that from the very very
beginning the creation of the nutrition
science field these seventh day
Adventists who are you know religiously
vegetarians you know you go back to uh
like uh the Kellog's Brothers you know
John Harvey Kellogg where he's out there
you know uh circumcising females and
saying we got we can't eat meat because
it's going to make you have sex and make
you have lust and masturbate this is all
like this religious stuff and then it
got people don't know that but they they
should know that that he developed this
cereal this blend cereal to discourage
masturbation which is one of the wildest
Things I have ever heard yeah that guy
was a wacko man he was in there dude he
was giving himself like High Press
enemas every day he was just like
20 gallons a minute enemas
because he thought that was something he
was a wacko he was a really nutty guy
you read about some of hisu 20 gallon en
it was some ridiculous like super high
capacity like a super soaker on steroids
thing are enas bad for you cuz I've
always wondered if your internal gut
Flora is important and it is isn't that
getting washed out I think to some
degree it is I don't know that anybody's
really looked at it from that angle but
uh I you know I I think in some cases
like you know some people's got some
problems with constipation it could be
helpful but I don't think it's generally
a healthy practice for most I know
there's people that are like like
putting weird stuff up their butt man
it's just kind of it's like I think it
probably feels good get flushed out it
might but also makes you see everything
come out of you I guess I've never done
it but apparently there's a tube and
they look at oh look here's your
problems yeah it's kind of like these
there's this thing these crazy vegans do
where they um they they consume like uh
like this charcoal and this jelly and
stuff and they this kind of GRL mix and
then it kind of like fills up their
intestines and they poop it all out and
they say that's that's clearing out all
my intestines I can't remember what they
call it but it's like there's these
crazy crazy videos where they're just
pulling all this like gelatinous black
stuff out of their butt but it's like
you just ate all that stuff that's
what's coming out of you it's not oh
look all the toxins yeah exactly you
just ate that stupid you just ate the
same stocks people are obsessed with
that term like releasing the toxins you
know they they really think that that's
what's happening when you sweat you get
in the sauna you're releasing the toxins
like when you're sweating your body's
regulating your heat temperature yeah
that's what's going on you know what
clears your toxins your liver
yeah that's what that thing's for yeah
liver kidneys yeah we got a pretty good
detox system for sure you you don't need
all the Smoothie juice fast detoxes you
know it's like somebody people are
detoxing when their teeth fall out
they're detoxing their teeth well the
the other thing is with with the
smoothie thing is my God you're getting
so much sugar and you're getting it in a
weird form yeah if you're in eating
fruit smoothies you're getting you're
getting sugar in a very unnatural form
fruit juices we used to think that fruit
juices are really good for you most
doctors would agree that fruit juices
are very high in sugar yeah and to get
it in that sort of liquid dose where it
just goes right into your
bloodstream and your liver that's a lot
of sugar man well you think about
because Jo you like you're out hunting
all the time you know you go when you go
out and you're like if I had to get food
out here what would I what would I have
available to to to eat I can tell you
what you wouldn't you wouldn't have all
this processed food but particularly
like like powder you know like we make
powdered sugar we make powdered flour
and we we we combine them together but
we've changed the nature of the food so
much that it's interesting you know I
saw Darius Ma zafari and who's a
researcher at tough to he's a guy that
put out the study that says uh was part
of the study that said you know like uh
Lucky Charms are healthier than than
eggs you saw that last year that's total
BS right but one thing he did point out
was that like over the last 20 years or
so we haven't really been eating much
more calories in we were like from the
1960s to about 2000 we ate more calories
and maybe that explains why everybody
got fat but since that time we really
haven't eaten much more but we've eaten
so much more Ultra processed food in
fact right now the US diet is close to
70% Ultra processed which you think
about it's like crazy and our kids are
getting fat but one thing that's
interesting is like you know because
you're talking about the microbiome
right our our gut Flora um when you eat
like Whole Food you know it goes farther
down your digestive tract and then you
know our microbiome actually consumes
some up to up to 22% of our calories can
be consumed by our by our microbiome but
when you're just eating sugar it goes
straight in you so those calories your
gut microb doesn't get any of that so
you're it's like you're absorbing more
calories so just by changing the quality
of the food you're changing how many
calories you absorb and that is what
some people say is part of what leads to
this obesity thing but we know like for
instance Well here here's another thing
the USDA came out with a study like I
don't know 3 months ago 91% processed
food diet is healthy you know this this
is what they're pushing trying to trying
to get us because they're trying to
position us to say was this study this
was USDA put it out it was probably I
think it was the Nova study I think I've
got I might have that on there Jamie but
um it's um it's basically because
there's there's some there's starting to
be backlash against Ultra processed
fruits I mean like South America
starting to ban the stuff which I think
you know I'm not I'm not for Banning
food I mean I think that gets into you
know freedom of choice and things like
that so you shouldn't B just like you
can still smoke if you want to you know
it's not the best for you so you don't
want to do that but at the same point
you know they're saying like this stuff
is there's a lot of backlash like people
like myself and probably you and others
just saying look this Ultra processed
garbage is literally killing us it's
making us crazy it's making us depressed
all these people with mental health
disorders uh a lot of that nutrition is
part of that and we can talk talk about
that but you know what they're seeing is
there's a backlash against that yeah so
that's a Nova Nova dietary guidelines
meet Nova developing a menu for a
healthy dietary pattern using ultr
processed food so they're basically
saying Hey how do we make people eat
more processed food and make it quote
unquote healthy and they showed that
they can make a diet that's like 91%
ultra-processed foods and still be quote
unquote healthy look what it says here
it says the purpose of this proof of
concept study was to determine the
feasibility of building a menu that
aligns with the recommendations for a
healthy dietary pattern from the 2020
DGA and includes a over
80% what is that
kcalories kilo calories from UPF ultr
processed foods as defined by Nova
designed to accomplish this objective we
first developed a list of foods that fit
Nova criteria for UPF uh Ultra processed
foods fit within a dietary patterns in
the 2020 DGA and are common ly consumed
by Americans we then use these foods to
develop a SE what that what is that 7D
what does that mean 7day 7 7day 7-Day
2,000 kilo calorie menu modeled on the
my pyramid sample menus and assess this
menu for nutrient content as well as for
diet diet quality using the healthy
eating index the results in the ultr
process DGA menu uh that was created 91%
of the kilo calories were from ultr
processed food or Nova category 4 the
hii 2115 score was 86 out of a possible
100 points the sample menu did not
achieve a perfect score due primarily to
excess sodium and an insufficient amount
of whole grains this menu provided
adequate amounts of all macro and
micronutrients except vitamin D vitamin
E and choline conclusions healthy
dietary patterns can include most of
their energy from Ultra processed foods
still receive a high diet quality score
and contain adequate amounts of most
macro and micronutrients boy right so
remember USDA the guys that go there
they leave USDA and they go sit on on
the board of directors at Nabisco and
PepsiCo and so this is really I think
what this is It's positioning us it's
positioning us as a society to accept
that Ultra processed foods are our food
it's really human pet food I mean you
see what happens to our pets yes and and
everybody's fat so we're going to still
eat we're going to say well it's still
okay it's okay if you eat your you know
your human dog chow or your human Chow
just keep keep doing that don't ask
questions and oh by the way here's an
asmic shot or semaglutide shot will
semaglutide shot will give you to to
kind of keep you chilled out so it's
really I mean it's it's it's almost
Sinister in a way it's very bizarre it's
very bizarre that this isn't challenged
and that shows you how captured our food
industry really is the fact that that's
not challenged the fact that our health
guidelines aren't set on hey what you
should be eating is what human beings
are designed to eat in nature yeah well
I mean is real food I mean I you know my
opinion on dietary guidelines because we
have a USDA that meets every five years
and by the way so USDA di dietary
guidelines P did you see there's a
physician from from Harvard named uh uh
Fatima Stamford right and she went on 60
Minutes and said obesity has nothing to
do with diet it has nothing to do with
exercise it's all disease and genetic
and there's nothing you can literally do
and and really and she's also sponsored
by Nova Nordisk who makes OIC right and
she's on there she's also a member of
the US dietary guidelines panel so 95%
of the people that sit on the US dietary
guidelines panel today for this next one
where they're going to come up for the
2025 guidelines all have Financial ties
to processed food companies yeah which I
mean you think about it's just like this
is crazy so so wild so if you go to like
Brazil like Brazil's dietary guidelines
or at least the on they released a few
years ago it was like here's what you
should do
um cook at home don't eat processed
foods and and eat with people around
that that you love and that that's their
literally that is their recommendation
which I think is better than our
guidelines because you know I mean if
left to our own you know I mean we are
now being told we got to eat all this
garbage and it's just making us it's
just making us sick it's
crazy